y una angiografía coronaria o
cateterismo cardíaco es un examen de
rayos x de los vasos y cámaras del
corazón que por lo general se realiza
para identificar una arteria coronaria
obstruida o estrecha que evita que la
sangre llegue al músculo del corazón
el estudio también se puede utilizar
para medir el tamaño y la función de las
cámaras del corazón y la función de las
válvulas del corazón cuando usted llega
al hospital se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y un monitor cardíaco y es
posible que se le administre un sedante
intravenoso u oral para ayudarlo a
relajarse la mayoría de los
procedimientos de angiografía coronaria
duran de una a dos horas antes del
procedimiento se lo colocará en una
camilla de exploración equipada con un
fluoroscopio un dispositivo que proyecta
imágenes de rayos x durante el
procedimiento el fluoroscopio se
desplazará por el tórax en todas las
direcciones para registrar imágenes del
corazón y arterias coronarias desde
múltiples ángulos
la mayoría de los cateterismos cardíacos
se realiza a través de la arteria
femoral en la ingle pero los
cateterismos también se pueden realizar
a través de una arteria del brazo el
médico anestesia la piel en la zona de
la ingle
una aguja en la arteria femoral una vez
que se coloca la aguja se pasa un
conductor a través de ella y se lo guía
cuidadosamente por el sistema arterial
hasta el corazón la aguja se retirará y
se reemplazará por un tubo flexible
pequeño denominado vaina el cual permite
el acceso a la arteria femoral luego un
catéter flexible y blando se deslizará
sobre el conductor a través de la vaina
y se dirigirá hacia el corazón el medico
vigilará el movimiento del catéter en el
fluoroscopio es posible que sienta
presión mientras se inserta en el
conductor la vaina pero no sentirá el
movimiento dentro de las arterias para
evaluar las arterias coronarias
el médico retirará al conductor guía
colocará la punta del catéter dentro de
las arterias una a la vez e inyectar a
un tinte especial este tinte le permite
al fluoroscopio tomar imágenes de rayos
x- denominadas angiogramas del interior
de las arterias las obstrucciones se
identificarán claramente a medida que
las arterias se llenen de tinte cuando
se inyecta el tinte puede sentirse
acalorado o con un poco de náuseas
después de haber registrado suficientes
imágenes de las arterias coronarias y
sus afluentes
se retirará por la ingle se debe aplicar
presión sobre la arteria femoral para
evitar una hemorragia luego se lo
llevará a la sala de recuperación donde
se le observará durante 30 a 60 minutos
pasado ese lapso se le pedirá que se
recueste boca arriba durante varias
horas con un vendaje de presión sobre la
ingle es posible que se le dé de alta el
mismo día o después de pasar una noche
en el hospital